hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to
actually films have come a long way
heaven but I mean on top of there being
continuing story lines great visuals and
interesting ideas we've broken quite a
few stereotypes as well today women can
be tough and developed leading to more
interesting characters and then can be
emotional and deep also leading to more
interesting characters this is the
direct opposite to the 80s and 90s where
they mainly just focused on one thing
being a male punching poop for my dick
on an explosion with Sambo it's Monster
Mile
we never talked about ideas or
expressing our emotions who we were may
on this this is and we do with the other
man's innocence it's work Schwarzenegger
my era for man
Weaver yogi berra VanDam VanDam Seagal
that was never a cool but will is mom
around
we were so blunt hon think we're not
feeling or thinking anything that our
hero for a while was an emotionless
robot who did nothing but till people
Michael Bay wishes he could be as fucked
up as we were but every once in a while
a smart film with sneaking under the
radar disguised as a dumb dick flick so
your friends would be like you want to
see if a person's identity is based on
his environment or his inner soul huh
recall that shit you wanna see Stallone
my ex mayor done politically correct a
Willian universe where they say - Oscar
Mayer wiener absolutely none of that
goes together
yep double ish a man wasn't a huge hit
with Craig's or the box office but it
did leave a lasting impact with people
many still talk about it because well
they have no idea what to clarify it at
is it a comedy is it an action film is
it smart commentary is a dumb violence
even today people had trouble clarifying
whether or not this is actually a good
flick movies that break the mold yet
somehow also stay bound to it intrigue
me
so is it just mindless action or a
clever satire of a future that could
possibly still happen let's take a look
and decide for ourselves
this is demolition morale yep I remember
when 1996 looked like that California
was on fire crime was everywhere
celebrities were fighting each other
while dressed like jackasses actually
what am I talking about this was only in
1996 the maniac hijacked immiscible
buses 30 passengers on it and I got a
real fit hunch where this passages are
be a kiss DeLong plays a rogue cop named
John Spartan going after Wesley Snipes
playing a criminal named Simon Phoenix
solar as the lone likes to say
she keeps is a million flavors of fun in
this movie too just a match of Ronald
McDonald and Beetlejuice sponsored a
human Happy Meal toy where are the
passengers fuck you where are the
Phoenix I swear I'd lose my head if it
wasn't attached I'll keep that in mind
believe it or not this actually made
moviegoers feel smart in the day like
they were clever enough to pick up on
that incredibly subtle foreshadowing
it's kind of showing Bambi's mom taking
out life insurance it's not as subtle as
you think
alone somehow survives that even though
we never see him exit
maybe there was a Coke machine in the
building when it's discovered that all
the hostages he was supposed to save our
dead bodies everywhere
it must be twenty or thirty this also
somehow lands him a life sentence frozen
in stasis how the fuck is that possible
the court will now listen to the
prosecution from an obviously lying
psychopath hey I told about the hostages
he said he didn't kay a compelling case
with a lot of hard evidence now the
defendant has put in years of loyal
service taking down hundreds of
criminals how do you plead yeah I think
the world would be better off without
the both of you freeze them he's put on
ice until years later when the future
has practically obliterated crime
presumably because of one night where
all crime becomes legal they don't
question and it just works this brings
us to listen Hut sleep played by Sandra
Bullock who is not in between Miss
Congeniality and the heat so she's
allowed to actually be funny here which
is more than I can say for always
greetings and salutations
welcome to the emergency line of a San
Angeles Police Department which movie
would you like me to ruin for you but we
find this future comes with a price
anything bad for you is illegal smoking
high cholesterol on educational toys
eyebrows even swearing gives you a fine
sanctimonious asshole
that's nothing to get down am i swearing
I put electric shocks on my balls it
really works
even though Huxley likes this world fine
she does long for the days of action as
you can see having surrounded herself in
twentieth-century nostalgia loser what I
wouldn't do for some action but action
is around the corner when Phoenix is
woken up for his parole hearing mr.
Simon Phoenix one of our first then most
illustrious members you will steal me an
Everlasting Gobstopper the Phoenix
escapes using the wardens eye to sneak
out he disguises himself as Dennis
Rodman the Menace when the police
finally track him down lie down with
your hands behind your back yeah
this is what every minority wishes the
LAPD was like the police are scared
shitless not knowing how to handle him
and he ends up escaping of course they
figure out the only way to catch a
maniac is to send in a maniac so the
unfree Stallone to go after him seeing
how his password precedes him sure this
is real life I have no joke for this
just everybody deserves to hear that
line they set him up against a cheese
grater and let him know the situation
the years 2032
her light was extinguished in the big
one of 2010 no yes we all remember the
big disaster of that year we didn't
follow you up for a family reunion
considering fortunate the lieutenant
even bothered to do a probe on your wife
uh I think that's the wrong Stallone
movie cigarette smoking is not good for
you and has been deemed that anything
not good for you is bad
hence illegal alcohol caffeine contact
sports meet by God it's a future films
run by MSNBC this is a cautionary tale
from tea partiers isn't it language
chocolate gasoline on educational toys
and anything spicy oh yeah if anything
bad for you is illegal then what's Rob
Schneider doing in this movie not many
people get a second chance John Spartan
Stallone of course takes the job puts on
the uniform and bar takes in probably
the strangest joke of the movie out of
toilet paper did you say toilet paper oh
they used handfuls of wadded paper back
in the trash I'm happy that you're happy
but the place what you're supposed to
have the toilet paper you got this
little shelf with three seashells on it
he doesn't know how to use the three
seashells and in case you're wondering
no they never explain how to use the
three seashells again like most of the
film I can't tell if this is brilliant
or stupid it's driven anyone who's seen
the movie insane
there's memes fan theories even years
later at the premiere of gravity one of
the biggest brown breakers of the past
decade what Sandra Bullock being
questioned about
it's absolutely nuts and I plan to get
to the bottom of it
Malcolm Tamara you summoned you will
discover the secret behind the three
seashells by the end of the review you
will present your findings to me does
that include yes you and the one who
explains it best will not be placed in
my spinal cord removal machine you have
I have two one for each of you as soon
as I bang my three seashells going your
task will begin oh but man you can't be
serious odds in your favor hmm he
rejoins an old friend who's so wise
Seiji in black that you're kind of
wondering how the hell he never made it
in a Stephen King film I remember you
were snot-nosed working planet they
finally grounded me shit damn before
they seemed to be friends he speaks to
him the most profane manner well if you
would rate my study you would know that
this is how insecure heterosexual male
is just a blonde fuck you doctor
Farnsworth tells him that the only guns
that can be found anymore are at a
museum which is exactly where Phoenix
ends up going to load up all the way
there he listens to what are some
typical catchy tunes
my god a future where everyone is
sensitive can't take a joke and is
obsessed with the past it's a future run
by tumblr somebody put me back in the
fridge what seems to be your boggle
Christ I woke up in Canada actually I
wonder if the next song in the radio was
this don't you put it in your mouth
don't your body in your mouth don't you
stop it in your face
still I'll make sure his weapon works
does him and Phoenix get in a battle for
who can make the most lame 90s action
but the founder of this new world
dressed as a White Castle Pope runs into
the middle of it however Phoenix doesn't
seem to be able to kill him that's
because the founder has programmed his
mind to go after another target isn't
that a thought repeating in that
barbaric brain of yours
the name friendly mr. Edgar friendly
don't you have someone to kill but he
didn't say would you kindly then go and
do your job
did he just say penis do you hear do you
hear it - don't act like you don't
did he just decide to play a sporadic
version of the penis game
so after quote saving his life the
founder invites him to dinner please I
insist I would like you to accompany me
to Taco Bell Mexican restaurants so
popular it was rejected from Mexico
twice look it up it's totally true
there's all for Humanity you might be
wondering why the hell was he invite to
Taco Bell of all places well in one of
the most painful of product placements
until Adam Sandler became a movie star
they give us this vague yet utterly
forced excuse you do not realize that
Taco Bell was the only restaurant to
survive the franchise Wars so so now our
restaurants are talked about okay screw
the seashells which I'm sure you'll need
to bring a lot of going to Taco Bell but
what on earth were the franchise Wars
was it like the burger king and his
Spartan cows against Colonel Sanders and
his mutated chickens this movie needs a
prequel but hey just what do you think
Stallone can plug anything else in this
movie the Schwarzenegger Presidential
Library wasn't he an actor was knob he
was president yes even though he was not
born in this country his popularity the
time causes 61st amendment which they
said no that's right he had it made and
then he had his name and everything went
downhill from there
you
so at this Mexican restaurant where as
stated before no spicy or salty food can
be served and so again like a typical
Taco Bell our hero finds once again he
has a hard time fitting in what would
you say if I called you a brutish fossil
symbolic of a decayed era gratefully
forgotten tar you kidding its Stallone
he hears that like twice a week but he
notices a ton of dirty hungry drugged up
people approaching the Taco Bell again
some things never change but he finds
out this group lives underground because
they don't agree with living in such a
fascist world
the last remaining criminal element in
the city but plans are in progress to
purge this peril from our day you are
even better live than a laserdisc they
could come back look this is in a while
worst okay her do people's not a good
thing sometimes it is but not what it's
a bunch of people looking for something
to eat again no joke just good wine so
we see Phoenix goes underground to kill
the leader of the rebels just so we can
come right back up to say he needs help
I'll need about five or six more special
the founder agrees to throw out some of
his criminal buddies to help while
Huxley straight I'll ask our hero for
quite a proposal I was wondering if you
would like to have sex oh yeah time to
let out the sexual cry of the Stallone
penis indeed but it's a little different
in the future as the world partakes and
what I can only describe as virtual boy
sex that came out much worse than I
intended as did that but you'll see what
I'm talking about
Wow sexual interaction is done virtually
without actually touching the person
you're dating this really is a future
run by tumblr not even mouth transfers
condoned what are you doing
breaking the law oh you are a savage
creature John Spartan and I wish you to
leave my domicile now she throws him out
but it's okay as part of being a Merion
movie we of course get some completely
pointless nudity who was that woman why
was it word to second showing off her
tits and ass
Stallone uses his alone time to knit
because after being turned down by a hot
woman and seeing another one naked yeah
that's what I would do but he figures
out his new talent it's all part of his
reprogramming when I thought out the
first thing I wanted to do is knit for
each inmate the computer draws up a
skill or trade which best suits their
genetic dispositions I was seamstress
well that's just great god I can just
see all the Stallone memes now I was
knitting before it was hipster can you
give me Phoenix's rehab program now well
he discovers that Phoenix has been
implanted with all sorts of hacking and
martial arts info that would make him an
unstoppable weapons so like guess the
real question is why aren't the rest of
the cops given these implants doesn't a
proper rehabilitation program no kiddin
this causes him to go to the underground
set of Super Mario Brothers where he
finally gets what he thinks is real food
this is fantastic
just don't ask where the meat comes from
inspector they said that rat
this is a rapper Hey after having Taco
Bell rat would taste like filet mignon
okay he comes across the leader of the
rebels played by Denis Leary who
explains quite clearly that the surface
world is tumblr than the underworld is
fortunately I guess you weren't part of
the Cocteau plan
greed deception abuse of power that's no
plan no this just delayed again nothing
much has really changed and it's a
freedom of speech or freedom of choice I
want I cholesterol
I would eat bacon and butter and buckets
of cheese okay I've seen this dude you
know what it is it's a 47 year old
virgin sitting around at his base for
Thomas freaking a banana broccoli shake
sing and I'm an Oscar Mayer week okay
are you sure this isn't a metaphor for
the internet but Phoenix and his new
gang spotted our heroes leaving him wide
open to be shot in the upper right how
is that possible you better shout
Phoenix to make me feel better
it actually does
the partaken Dukes of bile hazard as
bullet drives the car frantically while
screaming at the top of her lungs before
I became annoying
seriously did you just say your gun to
hit everything but Stallone today better
than you he escapes leaving Stallone to
crash but he's saved in probably the
strangest way imaginable and it saved
your life okay that's not a safety
device that's a power Mario would have
turn any surface into foam and I'm so
glad that gunshots wall slamming a door
spline don't set it off I think it's a
little bit of a delay I'll have a cop
launch to create the perfect society
nice Phoenix finds he still can't kill
the founder but like a moron he forgot
to program that into the other criminals
so he hands the gun over to a thug
played by Jesse Ventura yeah pretty sure
that's how he got his other political
job too he plans to follow all the
criminals to cause chaos which means
it's up to our two main heroes to save
the day our one main hero to save the
day
yep another trope of the mayor movie is
that the final battle always has to be
male no II me a No
yeah even though she's proven she's a
pretty badass fighter and even saves
Stallone a couple of times my testicles
must show I can handle this on my own so
yeah let's play a game called what
Huxley could have done lost alone gets
his ass kicked
my job I'll see you without much
okay she could not shout Phoenix that's
the one thing only Stallone could do and
even though it's kind of a table I'm
gonna make that my ringtone
in a kind of ripoff of Terminator 2
Phoenix is covered in frozen liquid
resulting in Stallone what else knocking
his block off I can just see the wheels
turning in Stallone's hands and give
every witty line
let's keep ahead don't lose your head
Henry David through one said it's better
to have your head in the clouds and know
where you were than to breathe the cab
fucking that's causing the big exploding
science ball to go off resulting in of
course the place being blown sky-high
or at least a small corner of it really
you open the movie with this and then
you end it with this I took up a corner
of the screen you still have all that
building to blow up it's like a domino
saying you never get to knock over next
to a bomb what we do how will we live
when they trying to figure out what will
happen to the future of Portlandia
Stallone give some advice I'm gonna tell
you what you're gonna - why don't you
get a little turd you would like to eat
and somewhere in the middle I don't
think I figured out Wow
not census thrilling speech to the
Russians in Rocky 4 has his diplomacy
ever been so eloquent somewhere in the
middle
I don't know you'll figure it out
thank you for rendering me unconscious
absolutely I did it for your own motives
hmm Huxley is rightfully pissed that she
was left out of the action but ah my
white knighting hero who I never asked
to be my white knight
this really is tumblr so that was
demolition man is it a comedy is it an
action film is it smart is it dumb and
most importantly does it hold up
honestly with no joking whatsoever this
is actually far better now than it has
ever been in the past when it came out
the action cliches were pretty standard
so at the time it wasn't a big hit but
now in 2015 these cliches have taken on
an identity of their own silly but kind
of admire this works especially now
because the future they created in this
movie is almost kind of true of the
world we created now our society thanks
to social media is trying to be more
about the group forums fan pages causes
to get behind hella there's a hater
online everyone wants to join together
and to prove how wrong he is compare
that to the 80s and 90s where everything
was about the individual Wall Street
make money for your own action films
mano-a-mano emotions are for the weak
but the great thing about it is neither
side is the villain in this they're just
products of their environment the future
has less choice but they've also blitter
a to murder for 16 years the past is
anarchy and violence but they also have
more rights and choices they both have
their pros and cons I know I joke about
the future being a commentary of online
culture but without even realizing it
that's kind of what they did the
internet is filled with people who are
overly sensitive and can't take a joke
but it's also filled with attention
hungry idiots who only want to anger and
antagonize those people but again no one
side is the bad guy they both have
villains they're the extremists who want
everything one way whether it's absolute
perfection or absolute anarchy
both result in taking away diversity in
free will while the heroes are the ones
willing to make a compromise Stallone
has trouble fitting in but it doesn't
say his world was completely right
eventually both sides realized that the
have to find some middle ground in order
to keep balance it's a commentary that
wouldn't work as well back then but
works much better now comparing our new
world to the world of the past our
current attitude to the attitude of the
90s now don't get me wrong some things
don't work especially well like the
actions not really that strong but some
of the cliches might be a little too
stupid for their own good but the
writing the ideas the commentary and yes
even the acting which is honestly pitch
perfect from every performer makes it
stand out I know it sounds crazy but
demolition man has actually gotten a lot
better with time
part of that being because they
intentionally date the hero and villain
by putting them in the future
dating it surprisingly made it timeless
and just knew which areas to update and
which areas to leave alone I'm totally
serious when I say this dumb cliched
overblown action film is actually one of
the smarter summer movies to come out of
the past few decades but that still
doesn't answer my three seashells
question Malcolm Tamara began
Tamara what do you have for me well I've
come to the conclusion that the first
show can be used as a scooping mechanism
you can scoop out to the yeah and then
you can use the second shell and put
them together as a grabbing device so
that you can actually grab out the M and
then you can use the third you kind of
just scoop out any residuals intriguing
Malcolm what do you have to say well I
had a theory that these seashells are
put into a device that shreds them down
to the most basic particles basic
particle those particles are then turned
into wadded paper for which is then used
for down there so your suggestion for
replacing toilet paper is just to make
toilet paper uh-huh that is brilliant
the world will call you a hero and I
will marry you as much of your money
gods take her away
wait we have guards you have done well
my tent oh geez
your future has just begun tell me
hey guys hope you enjoyed the review
just a little reminder
April 24th to the 26 is c2e2 in Chicago
and I am going to have a table there
this is a really big con one of the
biggest in Chicago if not the big is
it's definitely like a really really big
deal they have all sorts of great
celebrities that go there and just
really cool people I'm finally gonna
have a table there and the nice thing
about it is that you know it's not like
a panel we have to wait to have your
hand up whatever it's like you can just
come to the table say hi I'll have
merchandise and all that stuff ask me a
question whatever you want and you know
you just have a chance to chat every day
I'm gonna be there at noon and pretty
much just stay until there's no more
people to talk to so yeah go ahead drop
them by if you can hopefully in the next
video be able to tell you where in the
con it is because it's a really big
convention but yeah if not just come on
in look for me I'd love to say hi to you
guys so again that's a c2e2 April 24 to
the 26 hopefully I will see you guys
there
come on down Chicago and say hi take
care